the bottom line is that I I was all
consumed by my previous job which was
CEO of H&R Block a company that was
founded by my father Henry block and his
brother Richard and I enjoyed a 19-year
career of the company but it was about
at the time that I achieved my ultimate
goal which was to succeed my dad as CEO
that I began to think that something was
missing and I had two young kids at the
time and it was not uncommon for me to
sit at the dinner table and and my wife
would kick me under the table and said
would say Jason just asked you a
question and you didn't hear him so I
was totally consumed by my my job at H&R
Block so I finally decided if I was
going to truly be happy I would need to
pursue a different kind of personal
fulfillment one that was not financially
related and one where the focus was not
on me and so my thoughts began to turn
to urban education first several months
I debated back and forth you know I
think everybody I knew thought I had the
world by the tail having a wonderful
lucrative position at a great company
wonderful people and a company that was
founded by my father and so it was a
very difficult decision to make and
having been there for 19 years and
having never thought about any career
outside of the tax preparation business
for my entire life it was it was
agonizing and I would often wake my wife
at two o'clock in the morning which she
never appreciated to talk about this and
finally I made a decision to move on and
I thought about urban education for a
couple of reasons I thought then as I do
today that urban education lies at the
heart of our nation's most urgent
problem and I had two prior teaching
experiences neither of which was
in urban education but I when I was in
college my French professor offered me
the opportunity to teach French at the
elementary school in claremont
california and he told me i wouldn't be
paid but i could receive course credit
for it and so I did that and I really
enjoyed the experience now my students
didn't quite take me seriously they saw
me more as a 20 year old college student
than a real teacher and I think that was
particularly evident when they called me
mr. blockhead but then about 30 years
later I taught taxes at H&R Block and
also very satisfying experience and none
of my students then called me mr.
blockhead but so I thought teaching
would be a wonderful pursuit
you